Jesus said or a good Master what should
I do to inherit the Kingdom of Heaven
you know the story yeah Jewish boy so
Jesus said to him remember so Jesus this
young boy is asking Jesus the most
important question which all of us he
wants to get to the kingdom of husband
yes for kingdom of God so Jesus said to
him keep the Commandments of God
the young boy said I've been doing it
since I was young Jesus said to him you
are lucky one thing he said what is it
he said give you away and follow me so
Jesus never set in believe I'm gonna die
for you soon and you'll be saved that
was all who came after who came with
this teaching it's not about the actions
anymore about the faith in the Sun so so
we put as a Muslims we believe in Jesus
as like a family is your cousin or my
cousin yeah so we believe he was a
mighty message it's a true Messiah
however you believe that after Allah
raised up Jesus they the Roman pagers
corrupted the teacher of Jesus December
which is Christmas Day
[Music]
if you go back to the Greeks they they
had a good son for Mithra and they they
believe he was booked on the 25th of
December
yeah a lot of religions have a lot of
like families around them around that
kind of day around the winter solstice a
lot of religions have something towards
our eyes there must be something in that
right yeah so they're like the Romans
because remember when the the true cross
of Jesus they have more power
[Music]
they were scared for their lives because
the Roman pagans were after them try to
kill them they understand who came along
full and fool who was going around
killing the Christians he came and guess
what only us Damascus he said Jesus came
to him
Jesus that you know like I said the uh
I'm not sure if you're familiar with the
the screen the screaming that happened
between Paul and Jesus half brother
you know Jesus had to have problem
called James yeah so it's called James I
think James
they were going around teaching the the
the you have you you need to sacrifice
sheep yes but Paul said it's not about
the action it's about the faith but we
both came together they confronted him
is it true that he's going around saying
he's not by the faith it's not about the
action anymore he said no they said
you know
about the faith it's not about the
actions anymore about the faith that's
why there's no more circumcision
the Bible's been corrupted
has been corrupted
like how can you believe in a book that
you believe is corrupted and you're
still a Christian
you understand let me just give you an
example to show you that we're talking
about okay
yeah so
don't listen I'm gonna just give you an
example if you come back with 1721 here
Matthew 17
uh
go to Matthew 17 21. to show you
something
this map is 1721. however this kind does
not go out except by prayer and fasting
yeah all right
[Music]
all right
so we have
um
22. there's not 21.
number five yeah so when you go to the
footnotes
number five some manuscript inserts
verse 21.
so it's not here but it's here
so like which one is the Bible which was
the word of God
I don't know I'll just give an example
and there's many many there's many
passages is not here but it's there why
because this one supposedly that is
based upon the manuscript which is came
before the other one in the stand but
the question I will ask
okay I'm gonna give you a logical
rational arguments here what language
Jesus spoke
do we have the original language we
don't have it all right okay do we know
the translators who translated the
teacher of Jesus from Aramaic Greek we
don't know that we don't know yeah and
it's a very good point uh the book I'm
reading from us get translated three or
four times
because I understand something could
have got Lost in Translation no that's
about that for example if I say
something in Arabic
in order for you to know what if he
translates in order for us to know if in
order for us to know if you translate
correctly or not either you know Arabic
oh we don't have to be trusted honest
you understand yeah so when you come
back to degree we don't know the
translators
stuff so that's another one when it
comes to Quran we have the Miracles of
Quran Allah said the verse
we send down the deck of the Quran and
we'll preserve it yeah that is a claim
no doubt about that all right can we
verify it if we can if the Jewish the
Christians the Muslims all of them
decide to burn their scriptures the only
scripture will men will ask is the Quran
why
you know why because we have a hundreds
of Muslims whom was put and a word
forward Muslim children
Scholars memorize it too yeah looking at
the Muslim children they can bring it
back into the recent form and the Allah
and one thousand four hundred years ago
foreign
guess what perfectly foreign
he will learn from you then you will
come to me and I will teach you you
understand then it goes to him to make
sure there's nothing missing
I'll give you an example as well for
example I'm a non-arab here
there's certain parts of the Bible the
English which is my mother tongue even
to now those verses I have to paraphrase
I have to paraphrase
from the top of my tongue without false
where's my mother tongue in certain
verses the Bible or any form of poetry I
would make mistakes in my mother tongue
but yet in Arabic when I learned
something from the Quran a verse I was
able to recite it perfectly not to say I
would make a mistake in Arabic but the
point being as a non-harab how is it
made easy for me to memorize okay
is a bit subjective it is personal to me
but maybe if you learn a bit of Arabic
not say you know not to do it now wow
to God how's it that where are you from
sorry from Sligo in Ireland Ireland you
are able to read Arabic you know fluency
and eloquently obviously over time it's
obviously for us you know that's the
truth you know that it's called being
from God
because
the Quran is Allah's Revelation you
understand so and Islam is for everyone
when you capture Christianity Jesus
never came for everyone remember Jesus
Israelites who came from the children of
Israel or the house the Lost househip of
the Israel understand so my point here
is you want to worship God no doubts
but are we going to worship the way we
like or the way he likes
yeah yeah but um
which cannot be produced by any human
being
therefore and he came to your prophet of
God and guess what
so who actually wrote the Quran so the
Quran could not read and write yes
eloquent book perfect and best music
station yeah so Prophet Muhammad
received the Revelation
out to his companions and is to write it
down then read it out to him
okay yeah so that's what but we as a
Muslim we do not rely on a manuscript
because
memorization more okay why because
remember the Arabs if you start the
history of the Arabs the Arabs they had
not books before not like the Greeks and
the Egyptian and so on the Arabs were
known to memorize the line of forms or
poems consists of 500 lines or something
like that we don't know for it why you
know why because in our time I mean just
if you go back 10 years ago love us with
memorize five people's numbers yeah one
more is one number and follows you yeah
yeah
on your memory always exercising it you
become you know strong and so imagine
they had nothing to rely or accept their
memories and they want is to challenge
one another even they had a market
to The Poets will challenge each other
to see who has who has the the best
sport you know eloquency and style and
so on when the prophet Muhammad came
with the Quran he challenged them
what they did there was the war against
him but we know the easiest things to do
is to accept a challenge because when
you raise your ward we're going to lose
money you're going to lose your life and
so on so how come they live a challenge
and they waste and guessed it physical
work physical work they battled it out
yeah yeah because they knew the first
one is harder they knew even though
they're eloquence but they will make
themselves look stupid in their tattoo
compete and challenge God's words
you know that's why you know for example
like I said you want the Miracles of
Quran Allah mentioned that he made this
book easy to be memorized
there's no book
our in history it has been memorized by
100 million of people
word for word letter for letter like by
people don't ever speak the language of
their book except what come on
it's cool
so okay delicious that I came with
Prophet Muhammad okay
for example one of the prophecies
when interest not interest usually
interested will become widespread even
if I'm not involved directly will affect
you just remember because Muhammad
existed one thousand four hundred years
ago yeah so it's prophesizing about
something in the future Now by default
if you open a bank account your money is
being used interest yeah yeah
so how Amanda couldn't read and write
existed 1400 years ago even the word did
he said even if you are not involved
directly it will affect you
yes
are competing in building small
buildings
there was any indication that this
Bedouin adults they will compete in tall
buildings yeah and now where is the
tallest building in the world
you know that's why when it comes to
Islam it's not about I had a dream
you know I smoke drugs and I stopped
smoking drugs it's called personal
experience I understand Islam is the
truth because the Almighty
Almighty of everyone so only send the
prophets and Messengers he will give
them something which objective and no
subjective is that something that we can
observe and verify
one thing I will assure you about why
Islam is so special
things
people Universal necessity
first what is the pollution
that's when Islam paganism politicism
atheism
is forbidden we're not allowed to pray
Prophet Muhammad we're not allowed to
bow down to him you know because the
Oneness of God is so important Islam we
keep it pure yes and the outcome of not
worshiping the true God I will
demonstrate
so that's the first one the second one
Islam can preserve intellect
thirdly Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why interest and gambling is
forbidden yes fourthly Islam came to
preserve marriage and families and
Heritage that's why fornication adultery
is forbidden lastly Islam kept the peace
of life that's why committing suicide
killing people and Justice forbidden
so how do you um so there's obviously
like again I refer to that
how do people misinterpret the Quran in
terms of giving up their life for Israel
you know yeah and how how does that
misinterpretation because I'm guessing
it's a misinterpretation innocent people
in Islam is yeah so so where does that
come from like what part of the Quran
um have people got confused of course in
Islam maybe you heard this word Jihad
imagine someone it has a problem with
the drugs
yeah try his best to stay away from it
because you had enough yes so we have
something called what she had there's
different types of jihad but I'm going
to speak about the war yes and Islam
there is war but there's two tough War
there's a blame where the world and a
place where the world the world has been
legislative Islam is a place where the
world it is the war to remove oppression
and the tyrants you understand that war
the other state for for us is win that
the enemies of Islam or the tyrants try
to stop the Muslims from preaching Islam
so Allah should say the war to remove
the tyrants but so they took that
there's a station and there's like
innocent people in the name of Allah in
the stand but we have many clear
passages
you're not allowed to kill a woman you
know you're not allowed to even in a war
in someone imagine I'm fighting someone
with a sword and he dropped his sword
and he run away I'm allowed to go after
him you're non-combatant
yeah
someone has no weapon you know Islam
Islam based upon Mercy but also
based upon wisdom and Justice because
from foolishness
to let the oppressors get away of the
operation all the time in the stand so
so also it stand clearly tell us if we
have a contract with the non-muslims
we're not allowed to break it
for example someone come from any
country you have responsible or you have
travel documents or you have a Visa you
have signed
application for yeah we've been allowed
to steal you know how to do this yeah
I'm one of the signs of Hypocrites the
one that will sign the treaty then break
it
you know so so these people they they
um they misunderstood the meaning of
jihad
in Islam and that's where the problems
come from yes they misunderstood it and
but some of them you know remember some
of them they even don't know the truth
but they will utilize it to fulfill
their desires
try to utilize anything to to fulfill
their their desires and Truth to
manipulate the people but what I was
going to say about the five universities
yeah the question so when it comes to
alcohol is back to us individually and
collectively all right give me some fun
time zones no that's about that yeah it
gives you it gives you effective fake
happiness most of my best stories yeah I
go home and I tell my mom about yeah
we'll have alcohol so they've given me
some great times you know yeah whether I
would have had them without alcohol
but you were having yourself you will
have you you were harming yourself
harming myself
to my liver yeah yeah my intellect yeah
yeah
so it's like you know some people they
do enjoy themselves when they cut
themselves yeah but I'm not doing that
you're doing it in different ways I know
what you mean because it's harming
itself but you're having something
inside yeah I know what you're saying
yeah so that's why Islam does not negate
there is some you can gain some benefits
which is temporary benefits yes or fake
happiness because me myself I was not
born like this I live my crazy lifestyle
as well I used to take some crazy drugs
as well okay no doubt when I remember
you some fun time but it was a fake
so what are you doing you are trying to
remove the hardship and the and the
stress with something which is a harmful
and it's giving you a fake a fake
happiness but when you worship God and
you stay with this evil thing it gives
you the true meaning of happiness
instead and no doubt Satan always try to
Beatrice
sure in the standard so so alcohol is
better for us individually reflectively
no doubt gambling likewise yes
yeah it's because
you know in Islam you call it our
Prophet the mother of evil
yes so this woman she said this woman
she wants to have a fornication with him
and he said no no no it's Haram is
forbidden he said okay you hold it in my
house I'm gonna go up either you have
foreign
[Music]
it's done so likewise the interest
interest what it does make the retreat
yes very true also you touched on them
one of the it was the five police they
scored five Universal necessities
and I'm guessing that's where
um where that and also
homophobia will come in as well is it
homophobia so like I'm guessing the
Islamic faces
and I'm guessing that's where that's the
killer that's against the world yeah of
course yeah but not just that one even
how many stuff actually if you take you
down to yourself yeah yeah because the
part when they have intercourse is not
really create for that no but I think
in my opinion yeah the good that I
believe in yeah even if it wasn't the
right thing to do to have a family I
still think the Mind goes with allow the
people to do whatever they wanted to do
in order to be happy you know I think my
God and that's the only Christian faith
is against that as well yeah this is my
heart I just feel like you know like and
I've people that are very close to me
that are gay yeah and I think that like
like I'd love to know your thoughts on
this I'd love to know
how do you think about this but I think
my goal is
which good what oh my God yeah which one
oh my God my God right I mean which one
tell us which one I suppose Christian
yeah I guessed it yes but because
because look what you have to understand
you know it's not about feelings in the
stats it's not about what I feel it's
about exactly right
when it comes to feeding and you think
that the book you believe in has every
answer to every question no doubt about
that yeah 100 100 because is the is the
book came from the almighty the creator
of everything okay and even Allah said
the Quran
does he not know Allah
acquainted and on the win he noticed
creation you know that's why I'm gonna
come to this and I'll come out about the
lgbtq yeah when it comes to five alcohol
and drugs and all of that like we're
talking not just from watching it
they're glamorizing it glorifying it
yeah
is there other than technology is that
or Islam I guess they desires or those
who are in power those who are in power
they're making the money from this fight
can't believe interesting so they make
they look they look at Islam as a threat
to their business I understand so what
they do because they're rich they
utilize their money to make Islam look
bad even though Islam is good for us
individually and collectively you
understand also how a man that existed
one thousand four days ago who could
read and write he's coming with the
perfect way of life
because he said he already from the oh
no in the Creator understand but we'll
come to lgbtq when I said to you about
English you know what a very
distinguished Islam in a religion way of
life Islam is the rule of Common Sense
and natural definition yeah
where the gay people have intercourse in
a place will not create for that
even consensus we have a book here
scientists they tell you the the the the
the the the the
if you if you keep doing it to damage it
instead this is something which is
disgusting no doubt about that so God
will not allow us to have our souls for
the sake of what enjoyed ourselves is a
fake enjoyment because likewise because
likewise a man having fornication with a
woman
he's enjoying himself and the equipment
the nice person you miss understanding
but
foreign
for your family
and the messenger Paula told us if
someone really love a woman then marry
her because a man knows you know man he
knows if I'm gonna marry this woman she
has a right over me
I cannot just use that like a public
toilet just too much single leaves no
no just you know it's absolutely anyway
you actually take care of a look after
in the steps so so it's not about just
enjoyment
it's about what really because Satan
wants us to deceive us through what what
I got to join us when a person smoke
drugs
you can see I'm enjoy myself instead
much for fake enjoyment in the start and
that's what Satan
you know about the story of Adam and
Satan yeah you know if the quranic one
is so powerful so Allah Prophet Adam do
not eat on the tree
The Forbidden tree when the Satan wanted
Adam to eat from the tree you know why
he called it Satan he knows that how to
manipulate people psychologically yeah
he said to him or Adam so I'm not sure
of Eternity
Dominion
so so what happened he changed the name
of the tree the first one or the
Forbidden one into a beautiful name
tree of Eternity and everlasting Kingdom
that's what's happening now let's say
freedom where is the freedom to become
an animal just to finish his eyes not
about freedom freedom will you
understand your purpose
Freedom will you understand why if it's
a new Creator you don't want to
understand the true meaning of servitude
the Creator that true meaning of freedom
understand but look how they Twisted
they call it Freedom or they say women's
rights
women's rights if you want your right I
want my rights but what is behind This
Woman's right
there's something else you understand
likewise what is behind this one it's
some Freedom there's something else in
the stamina so what I would say to you
like Islam explain everything for us
everything so I'm not going to be
deceived by people saying I'm enjoying
myself
also you're harming God's group
when you worship someone beside him or
you just believe in God
but if someone said I'm not doing
nothing
you tell them who you are listening
you've been listening to want to give
you everything you know you you uh your
ought exists by his virtues
understanding so what you have to
understand as well this enjoyment that
we see is not ever ever one day we're
going to die
you know I'll give you example like me I
I really appreciate your time thank you
for giving me your time imagine during
this conversation thank you very much
like when I say I'm a Christian yeah I'm
very new to it yeah
[Laughter]
um
by
you know there's just there's so many
governments around it and I just
I just surrounded and maybe I will
finish yeah
20 years tomorrow are you guys ready to
live tomorrow
what I was going to say you know imagine
this winter today oh we're on the winter
time and it's a vehicle
and like four or five months it's gonna
be still beautiful yeah and I have two
houses I have one house made out of
board and silver and I have one house
made out of plastic so I will say to you
look you're allowed to sit in the house
that is made out of plastic for the
whole winter time plastic and other
things yes
but I will allow you to stay in my house
that is made out of gold and silver only
for two days then you have to be outside
in a severe cold which one you want to
choose
so while we're choose in this life over
the hill
instead so that's why no no no doubt
there's a lot of presentation around us
no doubt about that I'm not the best
Muslim I struggle myself all of us will
struggle yeah it's time every day
and it's so powerful and beautiful verse
all my servants those who transgressed
nor does commit sins transgress they
want beyond the boundaries yeah do not
disturb Allah's Mercy
forgive all the sins
uh you know what we say regardless
regardless how much sins you have
Allah's Mercy is greater than us
that's the beautiful step isn't that
almost
I don't want to have a problem with that
too right and like
and like like maybe you could like even
more light on this maybe I don't know
but like there's certain sins in my
opinion that should not be forgiven and
no matter what you do to try and get to
forgiveness I don't think they can be
there's a lot of stuff you know like
um
there's a lot of people in prisons I'm
sure that I've raped children that have
uh completely went against their human
nature almost and done horrific things
you know and can I stop you right there
if you don't mind
and if am I supposed to believe that
this person yeah if they ask for
forgiveness and God forgives them they
can be in the same Heaven that I'm gonna
do okay I just I can't I don't agree
with that I can't see how that uh
you know it's them when you talk about
forgiveness so there's there's different
rights of people yeah yeah for example
now we're talking about imagine I took
money for you I robbed you yeah that's
all money to do that yeah then you know
I want to make a toe by repentance to
allow it to repent okay
I'll say Allah forgive me but there's
one one thing is missing I have to ask
you to forgive me too
you understand so there's there's
Allah's right over me and there's your
right of me that is
that for you the repentance to be in
order for your Apprentice to be valid
and to be accepted and to be correct you
have to put this this there's a few
conditions one of them you regrets what
you did okay okay and you hate it okay
and you try your best because you know
I'm not perfect go back to it yes also
try to apologize and seek forgiveness
from the other person if they don't
forget that if they don't forgive for
example they have to say you know what I
want the punishment to be established on
you then the the Lord that the the
government established the punishments
but also on their judgments Allah Allah
is merciful for the day of judgment
Allah will say to the people will be
oppressed he will show them a place in
Paradise yeah and they will say who is
this for there's this place for whom he
said for those who forgive today
and of course when you see that place
that day
on that day you'll forgive anything
happened to you because right that day
on the day of judgment everyone's
looking for a good deal you understand
so no doubt is a great sin but you know
what is greater than that sin you
mentioned is this believing God I'm
going to forgive you if you return
my feet as far as I'm aware the only
seems that cannot be forgiven his uh
rejected
if you die opponent it's done and I
forgive all the sins as long you're
alive but if you're dead upon it and you
doubt upon disbelief but on the
condition because Allah is just on the
condition he didn't know for example
imagine someone living in the middle of
nowhere you never heard about Islam and
it dies as a disbeliever on the day of
judgment Allah will test him because
on the condition he knew about but Allah
will give all the sins so shirk is
greater than anything ever imagine yes
and undercover his belief but if you
refer to Allah and if you rush action
Allah
is a subjective objective subjective
subject if it's not based upon God's
teaching is subjective it means can be
right in the world yeah also we can
utilize our limited intellects and
opinions to charge the almighty Creator
the example I give you
like imagine you have a daughter or you
have a child yeah
and uh you go to a GP or a doctor and a
doctor gives you like injection yeah
so when you want to inject your daughter
your daughter she's like three years old
yes she will look at you as an evil man
she would start crying begging you to do
it yes so from her side
you're a bad person from her side you
want a hammer but from your side you are
good for her but what you're gonna tell
us all my daughter the capacity of your
mind doesn't allow you to judge my
action
why because my action is based upon my
intellect which is I know like it was
bigger than you or
more developed than you so therefore I
want to feel good in the stand but again
so so from her size evil not for me size
is good in the stand so
you are human British human being what
about us and the almighty creates so
when the almighty created legislate
something no doubt about it it's perfect
we should not utilize our limited brain
to judge the Creator but no doubt I'm
not talking about something against our
common sense for example God become a
baby
yeah
let me give you a book to read please
have a nice book please
talks about this
look we have this book read it it's a
gift okay sure yeah of course what's
your name my name is
every Friday every Friday here every
Friday yeah nice if you want to if you
read it yeah
you have Instagram this is our Instagram
if you have any questions after you
think you know what I read the book okay
I wanna ask about this or anything